hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous update you've
seen
the containers arriving with our kitchen
and workspace you've seen us chipping
wood
leveling the soil arriving a van from
matia
basically we gathered a lot of elements
but it still looks very rough
and in today's update we're going to
clean it all up and really make sure
it's a nice place to be
so this area is going to be the base
camp and it looks a bit rough now
and there are some containers dumped
there there's a van
there are some wood chips on the floor
here's some gravel from fixing the roads
so we gathered all the puzzle pieces in
place but
today it's time to properly set up
everything
so the containers are placed here but as
you can see the area around it is still
pretty rough
and it's quite exposed to the roads so
we want to clean it up and plant a few
bushes there
inside the workspace container we have a
big white tent which we used in a
workspace to melt plastic
and we want to put that right here so we
have some more outside space where we
can
put things so they're not there in front
of the town center you have this big
patch of thorns
which we want to chop out and really
make this space
for gardening we're going to move this
van a little bit more to the back area
where the vans are part
like mine and then we have this pile of
wood chips
here which you're going to clean up and
use to make all the pathways to connect
everything together
we're going to start off by cleaning the
area here around the workspace
the whole soil is still covered with
thorns and even though the bushes are
gone
all the roots are still here and as you
can see they're slowly growing
back so
[Music]
so the area is now cleaned and now we're
going to plant some trees
here to make a bit of a wall so first we
needed to buy some trees and we got
these cypress
because they are dense and grew fast
very practical reason
but logistically we didn't really think
it through i mean fitting 15 trees in
the car
i mean a bit tight but it worked
so
[Music]
okay
[Music]
trees are now planted nice little fence
still needs to grow
next we're going to set up the 10th
[Music]
so
go away
so
so
perfect next we're going to move this
little yellow cube
so now we need to put everything on the
floor
so because it might be a bit bumpy on
this side we have some boot from the
warehouse to
make it higher and on that side we're
digging it
and so it gets a bit lower and then it
should be balanced
is it good there getting there
so now we're gonna clean this area
remove the wood and the bushes and make
a pot there
so the soil is now cleaned up all the
thorns are out
next up we're going to make some
pathways around it so we can start
planting
[Music]
so the plan is to make a patch where we
can grow some herbs
but the soil is quite dense and rocky so
we first loosen it up a bit
and the aim was to make a big circle
shape like a
nice round patch which actually looks
quite
good from below until you fly the drone
and you realize
it's not really round
[Music]
and so after this we made another one
right next to it another perfect circle
this one was actually better and all the
grass we took out we moved it a few
meters further
around the containers trying to create a
new grass patch
so the soil is now ready next up
planting
today we are going to buy some trees
and bushes yes we're now heading to the
local market
to see some tree people
what are you hoping for
to find enough blueberry bush
and to find at least
two big enough trees to put on the land
all right let's see
tempura
this looks cool in the van some plants
hey exotic van
so what did we buy nick can you name
them um
so orange lemon cherry
blueberry
almond fig cocky
i'm one pair as a gift yes right
so now we have the fruit trees so we
will be going to this
very exciting tree shop to buy a few
bushes
we go to a tree shop to buy bushes
can i get one of these yes
can we also get a dolphin like that or a
lion for the entrance that would be cool
we have our trees and bushes so it's
start
time to start planting
[Music]
so we are now planting some trees and
the way we do it is to put some
manure in this case some bull manure and
then some
soil so that the roots don't touch
directly the manure
and then the tree cover it up lots of
water
that's it
so what is this this is an avocado tree
you can see the seed
right here giving birth to a new tree
you
[Music]
so rita is currently finishing up the
last trees and bushes to be planted
and in the background we hear some
thunder coming because it's going to
rain
and i think this is the first time ever
in all these months
that we're looking forward to the rain
so it's kind of a big moment
yeah rain
[Applause]
you still like the rain yes
i like more of the rain now
so all the trees and plants are ready
now
they were already watered by the rain
and next step would be to
put all the wood chips and creating the
pads
so the wood chips were using you might
have seen it from a few updates ago
where we got a wood chipper to chop down
all our leftover wood that was laying
around
and this has actually been super
valuable material
because the bare soil suddenly is not
exposed and we can walk on it
and so it's really good to have all
these wood chips around and we have a
lot of them
so we first just made a lot of piles to
make sure we distribute them evenly
and then we spread them out to make sure
we have a nice
thick layer of wood chips on our
pathways
[Music]
so we made a lot of pathways here
between the workspace and the kitchen
connecting them together and making sure
we can reach all our herbs in the garden
but on this side we also put a lot of
wood chips on the floor for the van area
so it's easier to park the vents it
stays free from the weeds and you have a
nice cover on the ground to walk on
welcome to the cleanup version of base
camp come with me and i will give you a
short guided tour
on the new requirements we did for this
base camp
we just passed through the visual
barrier we've created with these trees
that are very quickly growing behind the
trees we also planted some
blueberries which will give delicious
berries in the near
future workspace is set up
white tent is there and it can hold very
well
and dried the things that we just put
underneath when it rains
that it has been running quite a lot as
you can see wood chips are
on the path and they create the path
they make great sounds and they are
great
using for not allowing weights
to grow onto the beds but also to create
quite clear pads for people to walk and
not
walk all over and destroy too much the
grass
we've planted really delicious and very
good
smelling bushes and flowers
and it's an abundance of things now you
don't see too much because they are
all quite small but when they grow this
pet should be
filled with delicious things for humans
and
animals lots of trees like
oranges like figs
like cherries like cookies
almonds lemon pear
and an avocado just as a grand finale in
the middle of those beds
um and also we managed to
finalize a bit the van area so now we
have a bit of a more
welcoming space for the people so
you're welcome to come maybe in five
years when the fruits are ready to be
eaten
all right so that was it for this video
base camp is now
cleaned up not ready yet though we still
need to hook up the kitchen container
and the workspace to electricity
and this one to water so we're going to
do that in the next
updates if you want to see that make
sure to subscribe
and if you like what we're doing make
sure to visit support.projectcom.com to
see how you can help out
thanks for watching see you in the next
update